non credo che voi sappiate qual è il
primo rage game che io abbia mai fatto
vi assicuro ragazzi che il primo
videogioco range game che ho fatto in
tutta la mia vita che non ho mai
registrato sul canale tra l'altro è
questo che si chiama
probabilmente il creatore del gioco
quando hanno minato il gioco ha sbattuto
forte la testa sulla tastiera
il fatto è che i ragazzi ai tempi non
andavano tanto i rage game quindi
l'avevo fatto ma non c'erano stato
pitarque a eva non c'era stato sotto più
di tanto però adesso se riuscissi a fare
meno figure di merda possibili ok
comunque ragazzi nel caso non si fosse
capito queste ci sono i check point che
è una figata
perché non c'è nient'altro da fare se
non cambiare la gravità e andare se poi
ce la posso fare
sul caffè presente arthur uk map che
cazzo ok non voglio far domande va bene
così pour che aveva fatto è difficile ma
era veramente così incasinato anche i
tempi il poema per lo so
schivo tuccia posso fare me lo sento non
ce la posso fare piazzato tutto carico
sono tutto carico sono a norma un
macello
c'è veramente in credito per fetto vice
incredibile sono un fatto non ci posso
credere
if you prefer uk e impresa e io [ __ ]
che leggo pure bene madonna è va beh chi
sono sti tizi rosa cos'è sta roba quanto
si trovano così sto gioco che sono
arrivato alla fine il primo livello
fantastico cioè in poche parole c'è
tutto questo mondo tutto tutto questo
quando sono tutte schermate ragazzo
passando cos'è sta roba
sacrosanto gesù aiuto non me la
ricordavo che non è mai mancato c'è poi
non deve morire non devo morire numeri e
mica se muoio riparto me la sono vista
bruttissima vai zio corri corri sono un
fenomeno ne approfitto quanto dura cela
stavo facendo senza morire neanche una
volta non vorrei dire cosa ma roba lì è
uno di quei cosi che in quella roba lì
c'è un cerchietto non mi ricordo cos'è
il cerchietto raga fermi come si arrivò
al cerchietto no impossibile
a [ __ ] veloce un fenomeno cos'è sta
roba
hai trovato uno shiny 3 in cat 1 diventi
va bene e cosa me ne faccio di sociali
trink dovendo al mercato nero lo regala
una tipa oppure vi mando affanculo che
dite va bene lo stesso il bello è che io
non prende i check point c'è questo
problema di fondo e quindi muoio un'ora
dopo e migliori fare tutto non è
possibile è difficilissimo rega ministro
che era veramente difficile lo ricordavo
per un bordello ai tempi porca eva non
sono capace
ho preso che culo non ci credo veramente
sono fatta come ok bene c'è un altro di
quei cosi come si prende qui non prende
la madonna
niente c'è una coordinazione di 1 posto
un morto schiacciato perfetto come
dovrei fare zio spiegami cosa dovrei
fare spiega me lo zio
ok chiaro è andata veramente di culo
perché vado ok ok deve durare ancora
tanto sto livello perché mi sto
leggermente rompendo il cazzo perfetto
no porca eva morire tutta la famiglia
ok ma perché il mondo
nora che non è possibile ma perché non
senti ma che problema a ok
c'è poi per l'amor di dio datemi un
cazzo dice poi quanto tempo per un check
point di qua non so non sono capace
ragazzi vi prego che harry madonna che
culo guarda che guarda lascia stare bene
bene bye bye bye zio padova il silenzio
dei fari culi quanto quanto ci metti a
finire sto livello madonna quanto quanto
tempo per finire suo livello spiega mi è
assurdo e un'ora che continuo che ho
niente penso fosse finito ragazzino
finisce mai quanto dura casinò vedete
conto che un bacio ma perché ma non è
che per caso me lo sto rifacendo 800
volte visto che infinito è e non lo so
no ditemelo è che sono continua così
tutta la vita york lo spiega a mia madre
ecco infatti o dio mio dio salve brooks
difficile secondo ci ho messo per
arrivare qua tv ringraziarmi in tibetano
cinese zio no veramente prese capitano
ciao ciao fratello così contento di
vederti guarda io no vermilion ecco
infatti ti meritava il nome così di
merda ho deciso ragazzi mio figlio lo
chiamerò vermilion a mi segue ma cosa sa
perché lo devo portare indietro lo zio
facevi un pazzo un passo e arriva via
teletrasporto un passo dovevi fare uno
c'è un deficiente cosa fai tenti il
suicidio a questo sarà macello da
prendere ve lo dico ragazzi perché tipo
tutto a destra d'oro finir mi 200
scenari questo è successo anche figo che
a me gravità da solo questo ok
quindi faccio così bellissimo bellissimo
tua madre [ __ ] si faccia così ma la
[ __ ] muta manca tanto antipodi devo
trovare ma non manca tanto però non
perché non posso reggere più di tanto
così ve lo dico mette l'ansia sta roba
che ricambiano veramente ce l'ho fatta
fermi no perché sono un deficiente avevo
fatto la roma incredibile senza saperlo
io ti ringrazio ha quindi non c'è nessun
tipo ciano solisti trinca
ecco già zio fermi per mineo [ __ ]
cosa ci fai qua ci ho messo un'ora e
mezza arrivare qua non poteva arrivare
tu prima e far tutto tu a questo punto
ahimè il ping tua sorella helping che a
yuki aiuto è stare fermo lì mentre io
faccio i casini che che aiuto spiega mi
o no carte se sei bloccato anche tu no
eh
c'è vermilion che aiuta sono qua per
salvarti mi6 cosa non ho capito un cazzo
di quello che hai detto va bene a ok
adesso mi segue
voi comunque avete dei problemi dei
produttori di avete dei problemi
serissimi ma vuol seri però va bene a il
soccorso un membro dell'equipaggio ne
rimangono due capitano stai bene
sì però questo qua non è la navicella
non ci ha portato una navicella dove
siamo qualcosa è andato storto dobbiamo
andare cosa sta succedendo
e allora fai così dato visto che siete
inutili al caso e dell'equipaggio stai
lì fermo no ho detto di star fermo zio
ok bene non facendo è bella la vita e
lui non fa niente da comunque non vorrei
che tu ti stanca si troppo e zio cioè
proprio tanti ostacoli dalla tua parte
votanti ok adesso ragioniamo quasi quale
per sfizio lo ammazzerei quindi io
quando salto lui si avvicinano capito
si avvicina quando salto ok ok è stato
semplice bene ma viene mantica mattina
ok beh non so come ho fatto non piace
l'ho fatto ciao zio o dio grazie frate
te ne devi andare devi correre via
sparisci dalla mia vista sparisci ma
un'altra volta un altro livello del
cazzo scommettete no siamo arrivati my
fire è tener compagnia per million
vacation perde ragazzi miei va bene così
è stato alquanto tragico rigiocare sta
roba meno male che non l'avevano più
giocato c'era un motivo servite le
misurazioni sento come vi piace anche
vari social che come nido trascrizione
sui soliti di sky ci mettiamo il
prossimo video e da ragazzi